Let's discuss the solution to
our cache summary quiz part one.
We have a 256-byte cache with 32 byte
lines, and 2-way set associative.
We have a 32-bit address.
We need to know which bits are tag,
index, and offset.
Remember to always
start from the offset.
Bits 0 through something are the offset.
Which bit?
Well, 32 B is two to the fifth bytes.
So we need 5 bits to tell us
which byte we have in a line.
That means that we're talking
about bits 0 through 4.
This is five bits because we begin at 0.
The index bits are the next bits
in the order of significance.
So they will begin at bit 5.
The question is, how many do we need?
To determine that, we need to determine
how many sets do we have in this cache.
The cache has 256 bytes
divided by 32 bytes.
This is the number of lines,
and the result is 8.
So we have 8 lines.
It is a 2-way set associate cache,
so we have 8 over 2 sets.
This is four.
We need two bits to tell
us which set we have.
So it's going to be bits 5 and 6, and
that means that the tag bits
are starting from 7 all the way to 31.